- President Trump's announcement
that the U.S. would halt funding
to the World Health
Organization draws criticism.
The biggest U.S. airlines and the treasury
reach an agreement in
principle on financial aid.
And South Korea experiments with
holding an election during a pandemic.
I'm Shelby Holiday, and here's
what you need to know today.
- We have an investigation underway
on the World Health Organization.
We will find out exactly what went on.
- [Shelby] President Trump's
announcement that the U.S.
Would freeze funding to the WHO
has drawn criticism from some
health experts, pOliticians
and other personalities,
with Bill Gates saying "such a move
"during a major health crisis
is as dangerous as it sounds."
Democratic Senator Chris
Murphy accused Trump
of attempting to deflect attention
from his fatal mishandling of this crisis.
United Nations Chief, Antonio Guiteras,
denounced the cut and said now
is not the right time to look into
how the virus spread so rapidly.
Trump faulted the UN agency for,
in his view, acting too slowly
and making mistakes in
managing the pandemic.
A senior administration official said
the U.S. provided more than $450 million
to the WHO in the 2019 fiscal year.
U.S. politicians and the White House
have disagreed over whether Trump
can withhold WHO funds without
congressional approval.
Officials said 10 of the
12 biggest U.S. airlines
agreed to the terms of a rescue package
with the Treasury Department.
The financial aid includes $25 billion
to help prevent layoffs
and allow employees
to continue receiving benefits.
Delta, United, American
and others have been
hit hard by the pandemic,
and slashed flights
by upward of 70%.
The money will come
with certain conditions.
For example, airlines won't be allowed
to lay off or furlough workers
involuntarily until October.
South Korea moved ahead
with its National
Legislative election today,
the first in a country that
was deeply hit by the pandemic.
Voters were required to
stand three feet apart,
at tape-marked spots,
get their temperatures taken,
then sanitize their hands and wear gloves
before casting their votes.
President Moon Jae-in's popularity
has surged after his nation's successful
coronavirus response.
And his party is expected to keep control
of the National Assembly.